upon opening her eyes
lorna would always see the same thing
the floors the walls the ceiling
all sparkling with frost in the darkness
like the inside of a candy sugar house
still in white and glinting in the light
of the silver moon
icicles dangling like delicate blown
glass reflecting her image in miniature
here there a thousand places lorna would
slide out of bed wide awake and she
would hear her feet crunch on the snow
she would breathe out and release a
cloud of crystal air
the window would be frosted over but the
moon would still be glowing through it
icy illumination
and lorna would walk over and put her
hands on the sill knowing that something
outside had awakened her
she wouldn't open the window to see but
would just stand and wait
not feeling the cold at all in her thin
nightgown
and after a few moments she would watch
as five spots appeared in the frost
holes in the seamless sealed winter
around her and then the spots would
become
lines five raggedly parallel lines
growing longer and longer than the
length of the glass
and lorna would realize that the lines
were made by fingers
by someone dragging a small hand through
the thick caked ice on the window
she would try to peer through the lines
reality through prison bars through
zebra stripes
and she would strain with the cornea of
one eye practically touching the glass
but she'd see nothing but a dark shape
running away into the woods and wherever
that shape had just passed
the world would be white and soft and
silent covered in a blanket of snow
lorna had been having the dream since
childhood
i can't get rid of it you know said the
old man fumbling with the lock on the
front door
he was easily past 80 stooping and
nearly bald
the armpits of his yellow t-shirt were
sopping had a for sale sign in the
window for a while but don't see the
point anymore
i wasn't even aware that anyone owned it
lauren i fanned herself with her
notebook
glancing up and down the street which
was deserted
the old man turned and smiled reminding
lorna of a half-rotted jack-o'-lantern
everything's owned by somebody he said
he went back to work on the door and a
second later it swung inward
voila lorna peered around him into the
dimness
she took a step forward but he didn't
move aren't you coming in
she said i'd rather not
he was looking at her again and his eyes
looked as though they'd been immersed in
clear jelly
she wondered if he'd been drinking you
don't believe all those stories do you
he glanced inside the interior a
twilight grey broken up by harsh yellow
rectangles from the uncurtained windows
i just don't like it in there as all
he dropped the keys back into the pocket
of his sagging trousers
did you bring a coat lorna stared at him
it's almost 100 degrees
not marinate he jerked his thumb toward
the house
toward its half-scene entry hall then he
crossed his arms tight across his chest
as though he had felt a chill his skin
was translucent and lorna could see the
purple veins like tangled branches
beneath its surface
well try not to break anything he said
you can poke around as long as you want
he hobbled down the three steps from the
porch to the ground
when you're done just stop by my place
and i'll come back and lock up
lorna watched him as he made his way
across the yard to his own house a
little way down the block
the grass flattening with his passage
she waited until he had disappeared
behind his own door
before crossing the threshold of
winterhouse
well it's aptly named that was the first
thing lorna thought as she stepped
inside
it was like walking into a meat freezer
a temperature change so drastic that for
a full minute she felt faint
and had to put her hand to the wall to
steady herself
her breath came in cottony puffs and her
fingers and toes began to lose sensation
shivering she uncapped her pen and made
notes about the cold in her notebook
cursing herself for not bringing a
thermometer she made a quick survey of
the rooms
the house was not large and most of the
rooms were empty
one of the bedrooms upstairs held a
dirty child-sized table and chair
but that was all when she came back down
to the first floor
the light slanting in from the windows
had changed taken on a bluish tinge
it was still light enough to see but the
shadows in the corners had deepened
even though it was only just past noon
lorna had written a page and a half in
her notebook recording her sensations as
she moved about the house
in a way she was disappointed she'd come
here hoping to feel some sort of
presence no not exactly but something
so far she hadn't felt anything except
the cold was this the place that it so
fascinated her growing up
the house she dreamed of heard whispered
stories of after her parents thought she
was asleep
the house she'd stood in front of so
many times when she was a girl
rooted to the spot with a terror both
sickening and delicious
she sighed and closed her notebook
tucking the pen back into its pages
maybe writing about winter house wasn't
such a great plan after all
she looked up and noticed that the room
was definitely darker now
almost as though night was falling
scowling she checked her watch
its hand stood at 12 17. then she
noticed the windows
they were frosting over from the edges
inward a white camera shutter closing
lorna gasped as she watched the tiny ice
crystals forming on the glass
and she noticed that the temperature had
dropped considerably in the last few
minutes
i should write this down she thought but
then the idea passed from her head
displaced by the disbelief the
fascination the unreality of the
situation
i'm at home dreaming she heard herself
think or say out loud
then on the heels of that i'm freezing
to death
she could have fallen then she could no
longer feel her legs
and she knew that if she fell it would
be into the waiting embrace of the soft
snow around her
the glittering white shroud that would
wrap around her limbs and fill them with
its essence
turning her skin as blue as the light in
the room pulling the living heat from
her body
she felt gravity working upon her
drawing her toward the earth
lorna was snapped out of her trance by
the pain finding herself sitting
awkwardly on the wooden floorboards
the heels of her hands smarting her
notebook open beside her
she shook her head to clear it and
immediately looked to the window
but there was no frost no nothing just a
regular window with early afternoon
sunlight pouring in
she got to her feet brushing dust from
her clothes
it was still cold enough to see her
breath but that didn't seem so cold
anymore
she took one last look at the window
almost expecting to see five long ragged
finger marks
a ghost of them left there on the glass
but there was nothing
who died in that house lorna was sitting
on a threadbare couch in the old man's
living room
sipping hot tea from a chipped mug no
one that i know of
he had gone and locked up winter house
while she sat there
when he came back he'd introduced
himself as davis not specifying whether
it was his first or last name
i inherited it from my father and he
bought it from a fellow in town
hasn't been there more than 50 years i'd
say but how can it be haunted if no one
died in it
davis shrugged beats me far as i know no
one's ever seen a ghost or even heard
one in there
it's just that weird cold you don't go
in there though
lorna sipped her tea it was sweltering
in the room but she couldn't seem to get
warm
i've been in there lots of times he said
defensively scrunching up his almost
toothless mouth
had to when it was left to me but i try
to avoid it i don't like that cold
he looked longingly at her tea
apparently wishing he'd made himself
some
but you've never seen what i saw the
windows you mean
no i guess i never stayed in there long
enough lorna finished her tea and got to
her feet
she wanted to get home and make a few
more notes before the events of the day
had lost their luster
and davis didn't seem like he had any
more useful information
we'll all be in touch if i need to go in
the house again thanks a lot for your
time
sure thing and let me know when the book
comes out he gave her the pumpkin grin
again
she could feel his gaze boring into her
back as she left
lorna was having the dream again but it
was different this time she knew it
the first part was the same getting out
of bed feeling the cushion of snow
beneath her feet
seeing the finger lines drawn in the
frost on the window
but this time when the dark figure had
run away leaving winter in its path like
the white queen of narnia on her sledge
lorna's dream self did something it had
never done before
she slid open the window climbed over
the sill catching her nightgown on a
nail and tearing it
and then dropped to the ground below the
figure was far away
in the trees but still just visible
lorna followed it through the world gone
winter
everything around her silent as death
colorless save for the bluish cast of
the ice that covered the earth
she was not cold and she was not afraid
she didn't feel as though the figure
would hurt her
lorna had walked for ages through the
snowy wood pushing aside the black
branches
when all of a sudden she thought the
figure had disappeared
confused she stopped walking her breath
heaving out
crystalline in the black knight but then
she looked down and saw a small burrow
just big enough for a person to crawl
into she got down on her hands and knees
and wriggled inside
at first she could see nothing hear
nothing but her own quickened breathing
but as her eyes adjusted she realized
that crouching in the back of the burrow
was a little girl
lorna sat cross-legged on the ground
facing her what's your name
she asked the girl's face was as white
as the world outside
her lips blew and cracked gwen she said
she looked as though she was glowing
what are you doing here all alone
gwen stared at her with black marble
eyes that looked like holes
i'm lost poor little thing thought
lorna's dream self
she looks half frozen i can help you get
back home
the girl didn't say anything then just
sad and stared frail and bird-like
she seemed exhausted she rested her head
against the dirt wall of the burrow and
closed her eyes with a sigh
and suddenly it was as though lorna was
transported into the girl's weary
reverie
because all at once she was back in
winterhouse standing on the wooden
floorboards
and all around her the windows were
frosting over white fingers spreading
concealing
the cold had a cruel weight pressing
down and into her bones
and she clutched at herself desperately
in a vain attempt to keep warm
the house was growing darker and darker
the cold becoming harsher
coating the rooms with a layer of icy
death
lorna felt the same sensation she'd
experienced earlier in the day
when her waking self had stood in this
very spot that feeling of falling into
the loving arms of the freeze
succumbing to it wrapping herself in it
like a second skin
and then gwen the little girl was there
before her standing at the foot of the
stairs
and with small deliberate steps moving
slowly as though walking was difficult
for her
the girl mounted the stairs and began to
climb
lorna followed her teeth shattering
helplessly the cold had entered her body
and was killing it from the inside out
blood glaciating in her veins the girl
entered the room upstairs the one that
had held the child-sized table and chair
abandoned and covered with dust but now
the room was fully furnished with fresh
pink wallpaper and a little bed with a
lavender quilt
and the table and chair were new a few
crayons were scattered across the floor
and a doll was propped up on the pillows
gwen crossed the room
not seeming to notice lorna watching her
and stretched her arms above her head
arching her back yawning in a charming
childlike way
she pulled back the covers on the bed
revealing matching lavender sheets
and then she crawled in under the quilt
snug and warm nestling down with a smile
on her tiny china mouth
on her blue lips a smile that spoke of a
long journey finally at its end
of a well-deserved rest to come the
house went dark as lorna stood in the
doorway
the cold closed in and she saw no more
filtered sunlight falling on her closed
lids coaxed lorna from sleep
she felt strange uncomfortable there
seemed to be something in the bed with
her
poking at her arms and face she opened
her eyes blinked twice
and then sat up sharply she wasn't in
her bed at all
she was on the ground in the woods her
nightgown torn and tangled
amid the pine needles and dead leaves
that crinkled beneath her body
lorna looked around her seeing no one
the trees reached upward on all sides
and various bird songs drifted down from
their heights
she didn't know where she was and then
she noticed the burrow
rather small like an animal would make
but big enough for a person to crawl
into
despite the yellow heat of the morning
oozing down upon her
lorna's skin was suddenly swept with
cold goose flesh
fingers of ice on her body and her blood
she approached the entrance of the
burrow an
unsteady rhythm tripping in her chest
she knew what she would find in there
she peered into the darkness into the
hole where none of the sun's light would
reach
the tiny skeleton was there the skull
still wedged against the dirt wall where
it had fallen when the little girl had
succumbed to the sleep from which she
would never awaken
the bones were as white as a new
snowfall luminous in the blackness of
the hollow
lorna got to her feet seeing the frozen
woods of her dreams superimposed upon
the summery reality
and for a second everything was cold and
still the air pristine and clear as a
pure frost
even the birds had stopped singing as if
they sensed this change of season
this clash of opposing forces and then
lorna shed a single tear
a token of mourning for the lost little
girl who had dreamed of home as the
winter closed in around her
the tear grew cold as it slid down her
cheek and as it fell it caught the light
a frozen prism and reflected the
snow-covered world back at her from its
crystal heart
dawn never quite rose in the bowl formed
by the towering circle of mountains
and to manny their shadows slicing
through the rusty haze
looked like the hand of an earthen god
with its fingers upstretched
threatening to close into a fist
everyone else in the village was still
sleeping
as manny made his way across the palm of
the god's hand
the air twinkled with fragility ice
crystals almost visible before his eyes
but manny barely noticed the cold his
skin thrummed beneath his cloak
and his hands were crackling wires in
his pockets
his eagle gaze scanned the frozen ground
the lake loomed ahead black in the
eternal twilight
it hadn't iced over yet this year but
even in the darkness manny could see
chunks like sugar cubes bobbing among
the waves
he skirted the lake his eyes still
peering downward
and once he stopped briefly to bend and
pick up a long white feather with a
black tip
he examined it straightening its frayed
ends but then reconsidered and tossed it
back upon the frost
it wasn't a worthy token and besides
there would be much better things to
choose from
once he got to where he was going or at
least so he imagined
at one end of the lake a thin tributary
seemed to strive up the mountain's face
a twisting branch of shifting ebony
cutting through the snow
manny knew that the water flowed
downward into the valley of course
but he liked the thought of the water
escaping up into the foothills
it paralleled his own action and even
though his journey was a temporary one
he still felt an irresistible rush of
rebel blood
a heart quickening at the undertaking of
the forbidden
manny had never heard of anyone in the
village going past the lake and up into
the mountains
it had never been expressly disallowed
that he knew of it just simply wasn't
done
which was why manny had taken it upon
himself to do it
the morning had turned from rust to
russet by the time he had climbed past
the first blanketed boulders
and begun the trudge up the mountain
proper he followed the bank of the
stream
not only to keep from getting lost but
also in the hopes that animals were more
likely to leave feathers or shed skins
plants more likely to bloom manny's
excitement grew as he climbed higher
surely this far from the village he
would find objects the likes of which
had never been seen before
objects that would catch the eyes of the
females yes
but especially one particular female
manny smiled into the first scarf that
covered the lower half of his face
felon had been dancing through his
fantasies since his arrival into manhood
and he could never remember desiring
anyone else
he always watched her at her work as she
scooped water from the lake in huge iron
pots
and he surreptitiously memorized the
beautiful wide slash of her lipless
mouth
the gelat black gaze of her protruding
eyes
it was for felon that he had taken the
risk of wandering so far outside the
village
and behind his reddening forehead his
mind conjured up a vision of his 18th
birthday ceremony
two days hence when he would present his
creation in the village square
all the females would cluck and flatter
and press their stubby bodies against
his
but in the end felon would step forward
in all her glory
and bow her head down accepting him as
her lifelong mate
he felt he could explode at the mere
thought of it
an hour passed then most of another the
sky above the mountains was now a dull
goldenrod
the brightest hue it ever attained
manny's legs were beginning to ache
and the daydreams that had powered him
this far grew ever more inconsequential
the stream wider now dark and rushing
still chuckled alongside burbling back
down the way he had come
as though carrying news of his progress
manny retrieved a piece of dried meat
from his pocket and bit it savagely
chewing it with his jagged teeth the
sound of the stream
pounded in his ears a mocking racket
the loamy banks had yielded nothing so
far not so much as a shiny pebble
and the waters seemed to revel in the
withholding
manny walked yet farther the taste of
the meat still tainting his tongue
the wind growing crueler he would not
allow himself to return to the village
empty-handed
even if no one knew where he had gone or
for what purpose he would still wear the
stench of failure around him like a
shroud
he would rather go on into the mountains
and freeze to death than return to
felons questioning gaze
he did permit himself one glance back
over his shoulder and he was startled to
see how high above the valley he was
how forlorn were his footprints in the
snow
the palm of the god's hand was lost in
fog a distant smear far below
and for a moment manny found it easy to
believe that his entire life in the
village had been a vivid dream
that in reality he had always been
walking along this barren stream
walking up the face of this unforgiving
mountain searching for something that
would lie forever out of his grasp
goldenrod had faded back into russet and
manny's sturdy legs moved to their own
volition
pistons of flesh disconnected from the
controlling mind
manny had eaten the entire day's rations
and watched the snow swirling before him
with exhausted detachment
shifting black shapes began to dance in
front of his eyes
and manny had a lucid moment in which to
wonder if the shapes were boulders
or simply the opening gambit in the game
of oxygen deprivation that would lead to
his death
he blinked the blur of snowflakes
stinging his eyes
and with slow realization the solidity
of the shapes became apparent
forgetting the throbbing pain in his
limbs he took a few steps forward
fearing the vision would fade it did not
and instead
traced more distinct outlines against
the snow resolving itself into right
angles and human-made order
manny stopped again astonished
it was a village true it appeared to be
a
abandoned village the roofs of the
building showing skeletons of wood
the hearty winter gardens weed choked
and neglected
manny took only a moment to wonder at
the cause of the abandonment
whether it had been some natural
disaster or a well-planned attack
such things were not of great interest
to him he was here now and in two days
he would open his heart to felon
and hope that she accepted him he needed
badly to impress her
and here in this soulless place he could
perhaps find the means to do so
he plunged through unshoveled snowdrifts
and unchecked plant growth
the roof of the first house had
completely fallen in rendering the
interior impassable
but the next house looked virtually
untouched he eagerly pushed through the
door
and into a square front room littered
with any number of objects
that glittered intriguingly in the
dimness manny's energy and optimism
returned a hundredfold
he unslung the canvas bag from his
shoulder and began taking stock
here was a series of shelves that
groaned beneath the weight of
unbelievable treasures
the frost rimmed and rotting books were
clearly useless
but there was a breathtaking panoply of
colored glass objects
various sized vases with delicate
etching small mirrors with silver
filigree frames
globes with flattened bases and bubbles
suspended inside
manny could hardly contain himself as he
snatched the items from their lonely
posts and dropped them in his bag
not particularly caring whether they
broke or not as the shards would be just
as beautiful
if artfully arranged his gaze continued
down the shelves as covetus is a
starving man in a feast
and he gorged himself with more
loveliness a jar of bright-hued beads
a hunk of milky quartz a gently curling
pink seashell from a distant shore
manny felt as though he was floating
several feet off the ground
it occurred to him that perhaps he had
died in the snow and was experiencing a
heaven of his own making
he dismissed the thought as the objects
beneath his hands were too solid
too seductive but as he made his way
around the room
plucking random items from tabletops and
shelves he realized that a rather
unheavenly sound had been plaguing him
for quite some time
just below the perimeter of his
consciousness he stopped looking long
enough to tilt his head and listen
but it seemed as though the harder he
listened the more elusive the sound
became
it was almost like the sound was
sentient aware of his scrutiny
he went back to his work trying to
appear indifferent and the sound came
again
a sort of shuffling or rustling just
barely on the edge of audibility
as manny moved toward the next room of
the tiny house it struck him that the
sound could almost be a chorus of
whispers and furtive movement
the sound of many people trying and
failing to avoid detection
at the implications of the realization
manny froze
in his eagerness to collect the house's
riches it had not occurred to him to
check if the village was occupied
he had not called out he had simply
taken the brief evidence of his eyes as
gospel
and forged ahead accordingly but what if
there were people still living here
squatters perhaps who had taken over the
village after its residents had
abandoned it
or worse yet one of the whispering
voices and they were voices he was
hearing he was almost certain of that
now
were those of the invading force the
bloodthirsty savages who had decimated
this remote mountain outpost
leaving no one alive the cold seemed to
have permeated to manny's core
and for a moment he found it impossible
to move the room ahead of him was
swathed in shadow
and though the voices weren't
specifically emanating from there
they were many thought omnipresent he
swore he could almost see movement
a hint of black against black the canvas
bag felt filled with lead
and his heart was rapid cannon fire he
opened his mouth to speak
to ask if anyone was present but his
throat was paralyzed
the whispering seemed louder now as if
the whisperers had seen him and assessed
his weakness
and were perhaps preparing for decisive
action
manny picturing a hulking figure bearing
down on him sword blade glittering
finally found his strength and turned to
run the thought of felon and further
pillage forgotten
the second he turned his newfound
strength drained from his body
a dark silhouette blocked the house's
entrance
who are you it said the voice was not a
whisper but high-pitched and forceful
it spoke in a strange dialect manny
wasn't certain of the exact
words but their meaning was clear enough
still wondering whether the figure had
come to take off his head or if it was
simply a product of his cold and
fear-numbed brain
he slowly put his palm on his chest
manny he said the sound of his own gruff
rumble startled him
the figures stepped forward and in the
interior dimness its contours begin to
take
shape it was obviously some type of
human
but like none manny had ever seen it was
tall and live
with regular symmetrical features an
extraordinary skin that glowed pink
and was free of welts or crevices the
being pushed back the furred hood of its
coat
revealing a shining fall of hair the
color of waving wheat sheaves in the
summer
manny gasped at the sight of it manny
is that your name it pointed at him with
a long delicate finger
then it pointed to its own chest oni it
said
its voice like music on a gentle breeze
manny felt his thin-lipped mouth
stretching into a wide smile
oni just the sound of the two syllables
in his head was like the memory of a
pleasant dream
he could not tell whether the stranger
was male or female as it lacked the
clear tattoo that differentiated the
sexes in his own village
but whatever oni was it was magnificent
what are you doing here manny the
stranger moved closer
warily not returning his smile but not
seeming particularly hostile either
manny wasn't sure how to answer in a way
oni would understand
though to his ears their languages
sounded similar there was enough
divergence for misunderstanding to be a
distinct possibility
manny held up his canvas bag and rattled
it
collect for bower for felon
he put his hand to his chest again felt
it swell 18.
oni cocked its head like a curious bird
the stranger seemed not to know what he
was talking about
had he used the wrong words surely it
understood the bower ceremony that took
place on a male's 18th birthday
how could it not know that on the other
hand many thought anxiously
it didn't have a tattoo either maybe the
customs in this village had been
different
manny fingered the tattoo on his own
forehead nervously
he couldn't imagine anyone not having
one or not knowing about the bower
ceremony
this whole experience had taken on an
uncomfortable tone of the surreal
oni's brow furrowed and it crossed its
arms in what appeared to be impatience
manny wondered for a moment if the
stranger was really a human at all
it looked so unlike the people he knew
with their rugged hunched bodies and
crooked features
he found his mind wandering momentarily
contemplating whether the stranger was
different in other ways
maybe not even having two he stopped the
thought short
reddening to the roots of his hair you
can't just come here and take things
oni said apparently not noticing his
embarrassment
manny understood only about half of what
it was saying but he could tell it was
getting annoyed
oni pointed to his bag those things
belong to someone
manny hugged the bag possessively to his
chest feeling the muted edges of broken
glass
no mine now for felon what does that
mean
oni's perfectly spaced eyes were large
and seemed to blaze in the dimness
the whispering voices had grown loud
again an army of noises upon the air
manny shrunk from the stranger's obvious
wrath still clutching his treasures for
dear life
a long moment passed then the whispering
quieted and oni's feature seemed to
soften
i'm sorry it said the light going out of
its eyes
it stepped toward him again its palms
outstretched and a gesture of peace
come here i'd like to show you something
manny started to shake his head no
tensing his leg muscles to flee
but something in the stranger's
expression made him pause
oni was clearly upset about his
collection of the bower treasures
but now it appeared that the odd human
was changing its mind for some
mystifying reason
still keeping a tight hold on his bag
manny followed oni's graceful form
as it strode confidently into the
whispering darkness in the next room
at first manny could see nothing but
vague shadows but then there was a
scrape as a match was struck
and suddenly the small chamber was
painted with thick yellow light
oni's features dance weirdly in the
lantern's glow
and for a moment it looked devilish but
then the illusion passed
and manny could see that it was smiling
albeit a little sadly
manny's gaze followed the finger that
oni pointed toward a dim far corner of
the room
at first he wasn't sure what he was
looking at but slowly the details began
to form a coherent picture and the sick
fear in the pit of his stomach returned
for the corner of the room contained a
corpse leathery and shriveled
but undoubtedly the remains of one of
oni's bizarre breed of humans
the eyes had rotted away leaving hollow
sockets
and the jaw hung part way open as though
in a frozen and eternal agony
wisps of white hair still crowned at
skull and the limbs were draped in the
fabric of its death shroud
manny wanted very much to avert his eyes
but something about the spectacle held
his gaze there
someone perhaps oni had lavished the
body with copious decoration
including bracelets and necklaces made
from shells and colored stones
there were also intricately braided
ropes made of dried vines
threaded through with shining white
feathers by far the most numerous of the
objects though
were small bunches of unusual flowers
that manny had never seen
they were delicate and bell-shaped and
of an iridescent blue shade reminiscent
of a peacock's breast
manny's fingers itched to touch them but
he didn't dare
he glanced quizzically at oni this
corpse was decorated with the skill and
abundance of a superb bower
but he could not understand why anyone
would squander such exquisite
objects on a person who was unable to
appreciate them
this tribe of onis was certainly an
unfathomable lot
this was my grandfather manny jumped
thinking for a second that the voice had
issued from the slack jaw of the corpse
but no it was only oni speaking there
was a time not long ago when this
village was full of life and laughter it
said
and as though to punctuate the point the
whispering started up again
more urgent and terrifying than ever
manny cringed his
gaze darting into the corners where the
lantern's feeble glow didn't reach
oni noticed his apprehension and reached
out tentatively to pat his arm
don't be afraid of them the stranger
said gesturing around the room
they are all that's left of my people
manny wasn't sure exactly what oni had
said
but the touch of its hand had been an
unexpectedly welcome reassurance
the whispers were still close still
frightening but manny tried to ignore
them
and concentrate on the pleasing cadence
of oni's voice
i'm the only one left you see the
stranger said
casting a pensive glance at the silent
eyeless witness laid out upon the bed
at first no one could understand what
was happening why everyone was dying
half the village had perished before my
grandfather found the answer
the room had gone darker and the smoke
from the lantern made manny's eyelids
grow heavy
distantly he wondered if he would even
be able to get back to his village
before full darkness fell
at the moment the matter seemed less
than pressing
here was the culprit oni said reaching
over and fingering one of the splendid
blue blossoms that festooned the dead
man
no one really thought much of it when
these began to bloom they were lovely
and many people cultivated them for
their gardens
the livestock in particular took quite a
liking and ate them by the basketful
but no matter how many flowers the sheep
ate there would be more blooming the
next day
and more again the next the village was
awash and blooms
though manny didn't know some of the
words oni was using the picture it
painted as it spoke nonetheless became
ever more vivid in his mind's eye
it was shortly after the first slaughter
of the lambs that people started getting
sick
oni said its brow was wrinkled and its
eyes were shining in the lamplight
the gaze a million miles away the lambs
had eaten the blooms
and when my people ate the meat the
poison was passed on
even those who didn't eat the meat were
sickened when they bathed in the river
where the animal's contaminated blood
flowed after the slaughter
it was awful oni paused jaw working
and manny felt as though he should say
something to comfort the stranger who
was clearly distraught
he couldn't think of any words that it
might understand as sympathy however
so instead he imitated its earlier
gesture toward him and patted it gently
on the arm
this seemed to have the desired effect
for oni smiled down at him
my family were the only ones who were
immune it said sniffling a little
it might have been the fact that we were
blessed with this gift of communication
with the dead
or it could have been that we were just
lucky i suppose i lived in a house a
little way from here with my parents
but they both died of old age only a few
weeks ago
now i'm the only one left watching over
the village in its spirits
the whispers rose and fell as if an
acknowledgement of her words
the lantern was burning low and manny
found that he could barely make out
oni's face in the gloom
the shadows and sadness sculpted the
stranger's features
and again manny was struck by how
beautiful it was this odd being that had
lived so close
and yet seemed from another world anyone
as beautiful as that he reasoned anyone
that inspired such feelings within him
could be nothing but a female and from
then on he thought of her as such
with a tinge of regret he thought back
to phelan with her dear amphibian eyes
and bulbous nose
he still harbored affection for her but
how could he marry felon
now that he knew this marvelous creature
before him existed
he shook himself from his reverie to
discover that oni was looking at him
with something like expectation
manny wasn't sure what the strange girl
wanted so he simply nodded and smiled
then it dawned on him that perhaps she
was waiting for him to give back the
objects he had taken
his smile faltered as beautiful as oni
was
this was something he would not do not
now
even though he had decided he no longer
wanted to marry felon
he still planned to finish constructing
the bower and it was going to be the
most spectacular bower ever created
in the entire history of his people
nothing less would be acceptable
realizing that knight was descending
fast and eager to get to work
he gave oni another smile that he hoped
was apologetic
then grabbed a handful of the blue
flowers decorating the corpse
and dashed from the room from the house
back out into the sparkling snow
manny barely remembered his trek back
down the mountain it seemed as though he
flew back to his village on hawk's wings
it was only when he got home that he
realized how hungry he was
his mother had been in her cage all day
but he released her so she could boil
some soup for him
and cut thick slabs of bread from the
day-old loaf to set before him
she watched him as he wolf down his food
the f tattooed on her forehead was
crinkled with concern
but she did not ask him where he had
been his supper demolished manny locked
the cage door after his dutiful mother
and raced out to the workshop that
leaned against the back garden fence
the small wooden structure had once
belonged to his father but after his
death manny had appropriated it for his
own purposes
with trembling hands he set the canvas
back down on one of the work tables and
lit all the lanterns
soon enough the guttering flames had
warmed the room to a point where many
could remove his outer cloak
though not the wool coat beneath his
breath came out in cotton puffs as he
sifted through his newly acquired
treasures
he couldn't help but feel a little
disappointed that he'd failed to explore
the other houses in oni's village
who knew what other riches were waiting
there he mollified himself somewhat by
noticing the exquisite nature of the
objects he had managed to collect
and what an impressive display they
would make when arranged in the bowers
front chamber
only two of the glass vases had broken
so manny carefully chipped the shards
into attractive shapes
then broke a third vase to gather enough
material for a sort of mosaic he planned
once he had considered the best way of
showing off the items to most striking
effect
he moved to the bower itself which was
perched on another work table on the
other side of the room the completed
framework of the rear chamber was large
enough for a person to sit cross-legged
in
with a round hole in the floor through
which the wetting mechanism would
operate
later after the wedding ceremony was
finished the mechanism would be removed
to make room for the chamber pot that
fitted beneath
manny reached under the back part of the
cage and pulled the lever
noting with satisfaction how the iron
and wood hydraulic arm emerged smoothly
from the opening
its grasping claw sharp and gleaming in
the lantern light
he fetched a bottle of oil from a nearby
shelf and lubricated the joints to keep
the mechanism from seizing up at the
critical moment
the back chamber itself needed only a
perfunctory going over
manny tested the strength of the iron
bars and pushed on the floor to make
sure it could hold sufficient weight
then he moved to the other side of the
bower and peered into the front chamber
this was of equal size to the cage in
the rear but rather than bars it was
comprised of solid wood sides with the
curved ceiling
in the back of this chamber was a small
hinged panel that opened into the cage
he had painted the walls of the chamber
with dyes made from berries and crushed
insects
so they bore an attractive violet hue
but were otherwise bare
soon however this barrenness would be
remedied
manny had no idea of the time when he
finally stepped back from his work and
surveyed the finished product
his eyes were dry and pulsing in their
sockets his fingers were oozing blood
over the fresh scabs that had formed
hours earlier
but the bower was finished and it was
immeasurably more beautiful
than he ever could have imagined the
violet wall served as a shimmering
backdrop for his artful arrangements of
glass and bead and blossom
spirals of shattered quartz glittered
like stars against a painted sky
and everywhere the rainbow glint of
glass enticed the eye with breathtaking
patterns of stunning complexity
and topping it all off were the tiny
nodding heads of the bluebells
wreathing the walls and indigo garlands
their heady aroma permeating the chamber
with the scent of heaven
it was a masterpiece a work of genius
and manny's exhaustion and exaltation
combined into a sense of god-like
euphoria
this bower was not only the most
beautiful ever made by human beings
it was the most beautiful object of any
kind anywhere on earth
he was as certain of that fact as he was
that the bower was far too extraordinary
to be wasted upon the stunted and
fish-lipped females of this forsaken
village
his 18th birthday was still another
sunrise away but by that time he would
have already taken a wife
who was worthy of his wonderful creation
manny slept not at all after finishing
his masterwork
and though he was so weary he could
barely stand he could not wait to get on
his way
climbing the mountainside with bower in
tow would be a challenge but it had to
be done
and so he would find a way after the
better part of an hour was spent poking
around the workshop
manny finally decided to build a simple
sledge from leftover wood planks
and dragged the bower behind him this
bit of construction took more than
another hour
and manny realized the windows of the
workshop were now looking out upon the
burgundy glow that signaled the dawn
working carefully he attached the bower
to the makeshift sled
and maneuvered the whole contraption out
of the workshop peering around for
witnesses despite the early hour and the
high fence surrounding the garden
he pulled his cloak tight around himself
then tiptoed into the house
scrabbling through the cupboards for
provisions his mother still slept curled
up in her cage
her lips partly open she didn't wake as
manny filled his pockets with stale
bread and dried meat
that done he swept silently out the door
manny moved quickly and had rounded the
lake and begun the climb up the
mountain's face before anyone in the
village had even thought of stirring
his improvised sledge worked well enough
gliding over the frozen ground with
relative ease
occasionally shoring up against a stone
and teetering to one side or another
manny had to keep switching hands as the
weight of the sledge became arduous
but all in all it was a satisfactory
solution
the black stream pounded downward
carrying water from beyond oni's village
to his own
sustaining life along its fertile banks
the tips of the mountains above him were
a glow from the unseen sun by the time
he cited the first of the dark
structures of oni's village
the place looked exactly the same as it
had when he'd left it what seemed to be
years ago
the houses were crippled and desolate
the only signs of life the ubiquitous
bluebells that climbed around fence
posts and carpeted the neglected lawns
manny wanted to call out to oni but the
whispering voices seemed to push in
around him
suppressing his speech he had forgotten
how terrible they were when oni wasn't
around to control them
he stood in the center of the snug ring
of houses his hands still clutching the
rope that had pulled the sled
he wondered if oni was in one of the
houses looking out at him
perhaps angry at how he had run away
yesterday
he made a slow circle squinting in vain
into the darkened windows of the
cottages
he gestured to the sled and then to
himself trying to make oni understand
that he had brought something for her
surely she couldn't refuse him after
she'd seen the bower
the ghostly voices echoed through the
narrow streets a cacophony of hostility
but a moment later the sound subsided
and manny saw oni emerging from a house
at the far end of the square
her expression seemed to be one of
bemusement but she did not speak as she
approached him
manny was nearly jumping up and down in
his excitement making nervous circles
around the laden sledge
oni stopped a few feet from him and
looked down at the bower her expression
didn't change
and manny was confused how could she not
be overwhelmed by the workmanship that
had gone into it
the artistry with which he had fashioned
the delicate chambers
he felt his face growing hot and his
smile tightened
perhaps she simply didn't understand the
enormity of this custom
the importance of what he was offering
he would have a great deal of work ahead
of him
oni he said a little impatiently when
she looked at him he reached up and took
her hand
with his other hand he pointed to the
bower you
manny and oni he pointed to himself
she smiled at him but her face still
betrayed puzzlement
you made this for me she gestured to
herself
manny nodded vigorously perhaps she
wasn't as stupid as he had supposed
oh she peered down into the front
chamber and her face lit up
there's grandfather's things i thought
you had just stolen them
she raised her head and fixed her gaze
on his you broke some of his vases
though
mandy wasn't sure what she was saying
but she seemed to have got the gist of
the situation
so he kept smiling when she had
straightened back up manny said
ceremony manny and oni he pressed his
palms flat against each other
male and female oh
oni's lovely eyes went wide and then she
laughed a joyous ringing sound
manny didn't know what she was laughing
at but she didn't sound cruel or
contemptuous
so he joined her and laughed her perhaps
she was just very happy
now that she had finally understood what
he offered
after a few moments oni's laughter faded
and she stood there
looking down at manny in the bower manny
stopped laughing abruptly
why was she just standing there at home
when the females accepted the offer of
the bower
they put their heads down in deference
and then crawled into the bower for the
final portion of the marriage ceremony
the ceiling of the pact
oni was standing there tall and proud
deferring to no one
what was the matter with her manny took
her hand again
as roughly as he would have if she had
been a recalcitrant child
and pointed insistently at the bower
when she still appeared not to
understand
manny was forced to squat down and mime
crawling in through the opening
at last comprehension dawned upon her
pretty face
i have to go inside she asked and manny
nodded
hoping she'd said what he thought she
had she was obviously not taking the
ceremony very seriously
and this made manny very angry this was
not how he had pictured his wedding
but then she was not of his people and
could not be expected to know everything
after the ceremony he would have to
coach her more on the correct way of
doing things
he was glad to see though that she had
at last bent over and crawled halfway
into the front chamber of the bower
it's awfully small in here she said her
voice muffled
and although manny felt an almost
irresistible urge to push her in
he was just able to restrain himself the
females always entered the bowers of
their own free will
oni's feet clad and furred boots were
all that was still visible
once more he heard her muffled and
amused voice
what do i do now go through here he
didn't answer
since it appeared that she'd already
opened the hinged panel and made her way
into the rear chamber
now he could see her through the iron
bars see her expression
which was rapidly going from amusement
to annoyance
this is a cage manny she said flatly
manny said nothing she looked at him
through the bars
a beautiful bird of paradise is that all
can i come out now
manny gave her a stern look then sat
cross-legged on the ground
gesturing for her to do the same she
sighed and mumbled something under her
breath
but sat on the floor of the cage tilting
her head and staring at him expectantly
normally at this point in the ceremony
the male would ask if the female was
ready for the final sealing of the pact
but as manny didn't know how to ask such
a thing in a way she would understand
he simply reached over and flipped the
lever that controlled the mechanism
beneath the cage
in a brief moment he thought his flesh
growing hot with anticipation
the machine would remove the now
vestigial penis from his bride
leaving only the vagina which now
belonged to him alone
a supplement to his own pair of
hermaphroditic organs
the procedure he had heard was extremely
painful but quick
and afterwards the bride was truly a
woman a wife
manny heard the well-oiled joints of the
metal arm springing into action
and he heard the startled gasp that
escaped tony's lips
he smiled at her reassuringly trying to
tell her with his eyes that it would all
be over very soon
but her face had gone ashen her eyes
grown to enormous size and a look of
abject horror
there was another sound one of flesh
rending and then oni screamed
a scream so high and long that he
thought the gods themselves must have
halted in their labors
and pressed their hands to their ears a
trickle of blood escaped from beneath
the cage
shiny and dark on the dimlet snow and
then the trickle became a torrent
and manny leaped to his feet unable to
comprehend the sight
this had never occurred at any of the
ceremonies he had attended and he had no
idea what was happening
the blood was now coming in red waves
spreading like tributaries from a great
river
splattering his shoes seeping into the
frozen ground and inside the cage oni
appeared to be crumpling
shrinking as her life force spilled out
upon the snow
the echo of her scream still clanged in
his ears but the throat that had issued
the sound would clearly scream no longer
manny approached tentatively hoping that
perhaps some flutter of movement would
herald a miracle
but oni's slack face was going pale
against the bars
her blonde hair tangled around her
shoulders her eyes
open and empty before manny could even
begin to consider what had gone wrong
he realized that the still air around
him was now abuzz with whispering voices
spiraling upwards into the shrieks of
devils as the spirits of the village
rose up in fury at the destruction of
their sole living ancestor
manny's head swiveled this way in that
his panicked gaze scouring the darkness
for some sign of them
some visual representation of their
formless bodies perhaps as wrathful
angels descending upon him with flaming
swords
he saw nothing but the sound grew louder
unbearable
thundering and somehow it was worse
knowing they were there but being unable
to see them
face them try to appeal to them he spun
in dizzy circles
screaming apologies at the sky leaving
tiny malformed footprints in oni's blood
and still the spirits came like raging
harpies pressing against his body
stealing the thin air around him and
finally with a mighty cry he broke free
and ran
ran as hard and as fast as he had ever
run in his life
his legs pumping against the ground for
a brief moment he thought he had outrun
them
for the sound of their voices became
like a distant hellish wind
but then he felt his feet slipping out
from beneath him losing their fragile
purchase in the snow
and then he was flying through the
spirit soaked air the cold and death
seeping fast into his lungs
the shock of the freezing water as he
plunged into the black stream was enough
to stop his heart momentarily
but as he sputtered and struggled he was
able to roll over onto his back
flapping his numbing arms to try to stay
afloat he was so tired
so filled with horror and all he could
think of doing was floating all the way
back down to his own village in the arms
of the life-giving river
going back to his home and forgetting he
had ever seen oni
ever seen her haunted village tucked
among the high peaks
as he put his head back and considered
the cloud-choked sky above the bowl of
the mountaintops
he thought he might be able to do just
that forget
and then the spirits were upon him
shrieking down from above
and with their insubstantial weight they
pushed him beneath the freezing waves
holding them there with nothing but
their seething vengeance and the
tattered remnants of their unquiet souls
manny had a fleeting vision of his
stunted body floating in the lake near
his village
a felon coming to the lakeside with her
big iron pot
both of them would be there together in
the very center of the palm of the god's
hand
and then the water filled his lungs and
all was soothing darkness
you